he told a story early about how whenever
we came to town no matter what team i
was on
i'd call him
because even though we're planning it's
with his team
he's he's on the part of my list that i
won't have a flagrant value
i won't ever show on the pick
yeah yeah you won't even play hard
because i actually like watching them
play i've always liked big guard ever
since magic johnson i like big guards
ever since penny hardaway i like big
guards
and then when i saw kobe and i saw him
and i saw a flight like
a lot of people don't know i knew that
if after i left l.a i needed somebody
in that caliber to have a chance at
winning like i'm 29 30. i ain't gonna be
able to do it by myself that's why
that's because
i don't even know about dua either like
i just seen him kill baron davidson when
they were talking about trademarks like
i wanna go to miami
i think he was in orlando at the time
orlando still didn't want like i thought
about what i'm back home the combination
no i did i thought about going back home
think about that but they were still
tripping so i said you know just let me
go to mine but i just
they was still trying
i appreciate you
you know i love you
it's unfortunate that you have to fall
in that bs category you don't have a
championship
whatever i always thought you was one of
the great players you gave it to
all of the greats
love you respect you love your mama love
your family i just appreciate it no i i
appreciate that because you know
one thing you know throughout
our careers you know you have guys
and they like to label guys oh he works
extremely hard he's out of crazy work
ethic that man could tell you how often
i was at his house training before the
season
faithfully yeah at his house training
and getting that knowledge from him you
know as a young kid
growing up watching big fella because
i'm from central florida so obviously
orlando magic was my favorite team with
him and penny
and to have the opportunity when i came
to play for orlando
to go to his house and train to get
better and get that knowledge from him
sure the home is valuable yeah one of
the homies hit me and said take care of
my boy t-mac
one of those calls yeah no no you know
you know just one of those calls you
know one of the people say
this my young fella make sure you take
him so everywhere he went every city he
knew if he needed me you guys
you got one of those calls i don't think
anyone can say they've had a play like
this let's go back
33 35 seconds
13 points this has to be the play that
people talk to you about most the play
the series of plays see are you messing
up as a commissioner of this versus
thing don't make him show one of his top
highlights yeah
i mean
they've seen it we are giving roses on
tuesday people have seen this this thing
just happened last night shaq this has
been years no but it's a highlight show
we have to show is top right this right
here
this right here on his top and we know
that iverson's gonna cross over jordan
like we know these things
but this was incredible
yeah
most often asked about moment absolutely
that and you know a few others but this
one right here i mean
you think to do it against a team like
san antonio who's a great defensive team
right
bruce bourne pesky just you know
harassing you on the defensive end and
and to be able to have that comeback
against the championship caliber team
was it was phenomenal i was watching
cooper cup in the super bowl and i'm
like well they know he's going to him
and that's what that was like you're
like you know tmac is going to score and
it still happened it was inevitable well
one thing about great players i mean we
just got that will right that will to to
take over a game and that was those
moments that was the spurs team that
went on to win the championship so wait
i turn it over give mr tmac his roses
well first of all man i um i lit i live
by this saying uh i have a tattooed on
me and everything and it's my belief is
stronger than your doubt
and when i think of tracy mcgrady i
think of that you know when you have a
young player that's in the shadows of a
great player
and you bet on yourself
you know you you going to orlando
at that time
i don't think it was a popular choice
and you bet on yourself we got all these
people talking about battling yourself
and double down trace mcgrady was one of
the first ones that in my era of
watching the game that i felt when it
bet on himself
and went to orlando and just became
everyone's favorite player yeah
immediately and so you know i just think
as a young kid as we talk about with
little d and we talk about this power of
you know visualization and imagery to
have an image
of you know of a player that just had
the the silhouette that just when he
walked he was like oh he look cool
you know what man like he had the legs
sleeve on i was like ooh i want to do
that you know what i mean and so like
you know a lot of people don't like
t-mac was like we said when it comes to
like style how he dressed when he when
he played the game like we all wanted to
we wanted that swag we know that's why
we all put on that leg sleeve and so you
know i just think the importance of a
veteran guys we spent a lot of time in
chicago with tim grover um you know
we're down there rehabbing and getting
ready and i remember team actors to come
and do this hang dribble right and you
know that's all i did and i got it from
tmac you know just coming to i wasn't
six seven six eight doing it but like i
just wanted to do what t-mac was doing i
remember being in the gym and hearing
him on the sideline and talking about me
killing people with this hang dribble
like this shot and he was like here come
he go and i was just tearing people up
and i was like i got it from you you
know like i got the leg sleeve from you
and mj you know what i mean so you know
who he got to hang dribble from you're
welcome don't say you bro
i got a question for you man what
so as players what
the media are the ones that tell our
stories first for sure
and so
when you now that we have an opportunity
to tell our own stories like how do you
want your legacy to be defined as a
basketball player
um
i i think it was
it's defined you know
i'm gonna do the numbers
there's no greater accolade that you can
receive individually
than making it to the hall
i wasn't fortunate enough to play on the
championship team right
i didn't play with shaq i ain't played
with a d way in my in my uh my prime
and
not having that in my prime
you know yeah i put up crazy numbers and
i took to you know teams that probably
wasn't supposed to make playoffs to the
playoffs and put up crazy numbers in the
playoffs but i didn't advance
so my reward in my championship
was to make it to the hall of fame
that to me i mean that's
that's why i don't get so caught up in
he didn't win a chip it's it's a lot of
moving parts that comes with winning
championships right shaq's most dominant
guy to ever play our game he has four
championships it's hard yeah right and
how many years you played big
19 way 19 and he has four champions it's
hard to win a chip because it's a lot of
moving parts and and to me i don't know
how you guys feel going this every
season is probably like four teams
trying to win a ship right you know what
i mean
right realistically trying to win a
championship so
um
yeah man
hof man i got that beautiful thing no no
no ho h-o-f-f-a offer
something something that a lot of people
don't know